so we started going through the list of
the biggest threat to america and we
have a list of maybe 40 or 50 different
things and we narrowed it down to two
things the obvious threat and the not so
obvious threat and we're gonna cover
that with you today in the video
so let's go through the obvious first
you know how when people say the biggest
threat to america is itself i have met
the enemy at his eye great we know that
china of course modern warfare bio cyber
nuclear emp
those are very likely to happen the next
5 10 15 20 30 years debt taxes social
media common sense ai virtual
governments fear-mongering these are the
obvious some may even say these are not
the obvious but we're putting these as
the obvious i want to focus on the not
so obvious today with the first one
being hyper
anything but specifically hypersensitive
today
we are so much about walking on x shows
anything you say you got to be so
careful because god forbid you say the
wrong thing you know how in the world
the business that will tell you two
things you should never talk about you
should never talk about religion and
politics you should focus on sports and
others but not religion and politics yes
i have a one of my neighbors came over
for a kiss and got to get a hedge fund
manager worth a couple hundred million
dollars and his wife is sitting in front
of me husband here my wife said we're
having a conversation to get our kids
are playing you know what we talked
about what do you think we talked about
religion and politics is what we talked
about because most people at that level
want to have those types of
conversations but today
we're forced to be so hypersensitive
walking on eggshells that you're forced
to be fake and who the hell likes fake
people you don't even like it when you
have to be fake but we can no longer
talk because it's so hyper sensitive if
you have the courage to still do it but
most people are afraid of it number two
force diversity
over meritocracy forced diversity over
meritocracy
i had one of my uh folks that came to
the home office
and they were looking at the company
and they said hey why is it that the
majority of the employees here
are you know a certain ethnicity was you
know you have so many african-americans
working here why is that i said i said
what does that have to do with anything
the job gets done you know we have more
women than men i look for people that
can get the job done it's meritocracy we
don't look for and in a specific
position we focus on recruiting people
from certain area why because
meritocracy but today
today it's about forced diversity you
know you should be you know like the
delta airlines just announced forced
diversity over meritocracy why we have
to announce that such and such
percentages this and such and such
percentage is this because we have to be
inclusive no it's meritocracy who can
get the job done the most i am from iran
i'm middle eastern i don't have a
four-year i don't have a two-year degree
okay you probably shouldn't hire me as
an engineer just to meet your guidelines
i am not a good engineer you probably
shouldn't hire me to do a lot of jobs
but when i came up because capitalism is
a meritocracy type of an environment
even without anything on my resume i
moved up simply because meritocracy
we're kind of getting away from that and
it's a little concerning number three
extreme ideology and on both sides by
the way left and right extreme extreme
ideology
is what gets a nation to be divided a
little bit more in the center but we got
a lot of extreme ideologies today again
that's one of the bigger threats number
four educational system okay that we
have today professors they have so much
influence over the kids so much
influence over the kids i had a guy that
i was talking to
he says you know my daughter and i were
best friends he says and then i sent my
kids to my daughter to uc berkeley and
all of a sudden while she's going to
school
she started hating me i've never heard
my daughter talk to me this way before
we were talking and it was a fight it
was as if she despised me
and four years later she doesn't even
want to come back home she doesn't even
want to see us she doesn't even want to
be at thanksgiving my daughter and i
were like this together we were best of
friends now she doesn't want to see me
how the hell did that happen
educational system and professors when
they go to school they're demonizing so
many job creators rich people
capitalists all these other people
confused confused confused the
educational system right now needs and
by the way even if we talk about the
educational on the math side america is
not one the highest ranking on math it's
more about well let's not hurt each
other's feelings new york city the other
day
de blasio just announced that they're
getting away with the ap program and the
honor program because it makes people
feel inferior listen i've never once
taken ap and i've never once taken a
honors and i never deserved to have
taken ap or honors because i sucked in
school and they gave me the right
classes never in my life have i taken
english 101 do you know why because i
was not good in english not because i
was offended by it i was simply not good
for it today it's all about we cannot
hurt kids feelings now if you don't do
the work you don't deserve to go there
so again the educational system
professors one of the biggest threats we
have number five demonizing success and
well so you know when when you see
somebody who is becoming successful back
in the days it was the life but the rich
and famous people were so curious let me
see the life of the rich what is it like
to be the life of the rich and famous
today you almost don't want to tell
people you're rich today you almost
don't want to tell people you have money
today you almost want to be like well no
we're really struggling you know it's
not really that good family because if
you do god forbid you're rich and famous
demonizing demonizing demonizing
where it's almost flipping what the
american dream is today used to say the
america you're such a you're the
american dream this is the american
dream today the american dream is a very
confusing american dream because they're
redefining it so
we've gotten away from elevating people
who are winning and we're demonizing
them today number six redefining role
models heroes which kind of goes with
number five so imagine when you were a
kid growing up your mom dad we used to
say you know look at such and such he's
such a role model look at this cousin of
yours our grandfather was this
and look at your brother or look at this
friend and it was annoying you know what
i'm talking with that whole thing was
taking place it was kind of annoying
right whenever your parents do it
but who was that role model you as a kid
you kind of were like
man one day let me be that person to
impress my mom let me one day be like
that man to make my dad like proud of me
right those magical words we want to
hear from our parents as kids you know
what i'm talking about right okay
today the media is redefining heroes
okay today the hero is a person that
doesn't want to work anymore and they're
sitting home and saying well it's not
all about money i'd rather home stay
home and take the entitlements from the
government what a hero you're standing
up for what you believe in
we are so confusing kids what a true
hero is today that the younger
generation has no clue what a real hero
is they're so confused on who to look up
to like they used to back in the days
it's redefining
the role models that we once used to
have number seven opioid epidemic
escaping reality uh years ago in the 70s
the shop iran was being interviewed by
bbc
and he said what do you think is a
challenge with the west he says the west
is solving problems by taking one too
many sleeping pills
your entire generation is in the
sleeping pill generation he was saying
this in the 70s think about 2021 they
showed statistics on opioid suicide
last year record-breaking year and what
you know what it's looked like since
2010 is like this it's like this 96 000
give or take people committed suicide
opioid linked to opioid it is a epidemic
that's taking place and it's another one
of those oh you have your you're too
much pain here take this oh you're
trying to escape this take this
everything's about solving these doctors
are solving any you send the kid to go
see a psychologist or a psychiatrist
like one of those guys that can give the
prescription say oh you're going through
this here go get this
i'm sorry i'm trying to talk to you no
no just go take this take two of these a
day everything is immediate then we're
not paying a lot of attention to it this
is emotional to me because i lost a
friend over this simply because he went
with
life is too painful take one vicodin
take two vicodin take 10 vicodin take 50
vicodin boom guy we lose them years ago
and that was due to opioids so this is
gradually coming up and the younger
generation is being linked to this a lot
lately number eight open borders
you're seeing what's going on it's like
ah you know it is what it is now it's an
issue but it's not that big of an issue
you know who comes up through the
borders who do you think comes up
through the borders and i'm not
endorsing a wall or any of that stuff
although the wall is not a bad idea but
not paying attention to the borders what
do you think happens if there's no
borders when eventually don't have
borders who comes in anybody and
everybody and it's not latinos i'm
talking about
middle east doesn't come straight here
middle east goes here then they come up
they see the borders and this it's so
easy to come to america just go like
this it's a piece of cake for us to do
this go like this and we're not paying
attention to too much as a person who
lived in iran and see a lot of this
stuff taking place and then all of a
sudden the place went into shambles some
of that stuff is taking place in america
today number nine inability to entertain
opposing ideas we have a hard time doing
that today we used to be able to do it
we have a hard time doing it today
because we get offended so easily
there's no way i'm even gonna let you
talk about that it's an opposing idea
let's just have a talk about it whether
you agree or not we have a hard time
with that today number 10 demonizing
faith
in a higher power it's almost like
thinking about somebody as a higher
power is like no no no it's not good for
people to have faith you know god
doesn't exist no this you guys are fools
you're naive if you think god exists
let's say you're right god doesn't exist
let's say they're right god does exist
but the reality part of it is the
following you know what happens when a
populist loses faith they no longer
think they can stand up to a larger
government organization if you look at
dietrich bonhoeffer if you look at any
of the communistic regimes the first
rule is is to get people to stop
believing in a god the more you stop
believing in a god the more the less
faith you have to stand up because you
think you're helpless some of the
greatest leaders of our time that
started a great where they could stand
up to the bigger powerful people is they
had faith and a higher power so we're
gradually kind of and by the way this is
not a religion plug this is just faith
period we're demonizing faith in a
higher power number 11 destruction of
strong family values
you know what it means to have strong
family values fatherless homes you know
what marriage means what parenting means
what kids all of that stuff we're losing
some of those values number 12 is
restriction incentive model so meaning
back in the days in my house if you read
books you get what you want that's my
currency my house right in a different
person's house the you know incentive
model may be different incentive in
america you start a business here's the
tax benefits you get you do this you get
these tax write-ups you get this you
create jobs you get this we're changing
the incentive model with the incentive
is you stay home and don't work we'll
send you money oh so if i don't work i
get money yes that's redefining and
restructuring the incentive model to
make you more liability you're more
relying on the government to take care
of you you have to subtly pay attention
to this because this is changing this
changes behavior number 13
censorship freedom of speech people are
the fear of god forbid i use a certain
word
youtube the other day took like 10 of
our videos down just because one word
was in it and what do you think that one
word is ten videos were just taking that
because
simple ward being talked about the
censorship freedom of speech you can't
talk about this that is a very big
threat that's facing america today begin
if you're if you're censoring that what
happens there's no opposing ideas if
there's no an ability to pose ideas then
how do we learn we learn through debate
we learn through clash of ideas we're
kind of getting away from that number 14
lack of competition fear of losing
by far one of the best things that helps
all of us improve ideas companies
products
sale
price point all of it is competition if
there's no competition nobody has to
lower their prices if there's no
competition nobody has to offer better
customer service if there's no
competition nobody has to pay their
employees better if there's no customers
competition nobody has to give their
employees better benefits if there's no
competition why would i give you a
retirement plan if there's no
competition why would i give you equity
i don't have to give it to you there is
no competition competition is the best
for people for employees for people that
want to do big things we're kind of
getting away from that and it's all
about no no no we can't have competition
it's more let one organization have a
lot of power we need a lot of
competition today number 15 is cancel
culture tied to censorship god forbid
you say the wrong thing or you said
something 11 years ago right now
football coaches going through it today
we don't agree with the comments but it
was said 11 years ago if you and i got
judged based on what we did 20 30 10
years ago all of us would probably lose
our jobs that if everything you ever
said was recorded if everything you ever
said was recorded and something you said
10 years ago you regret you could lose
your job today that's cancel culture
that's a little
slippery slope for a lot of people
number 16 pinning people against each
other men against women whites against
blacks
you know religious against non-religious
parents against kids employer against
employee pen pen pen look we're in a
very competitive
culture in america right we like ufc we
like boxing while they're against fury
we like competition right but that
competition is for entertainment this
competition is for division there's a
very big difference between the two very
very big difference between the two 17.
lack of statesmen politicians who stand
up people get into politics who really
don't want to get into politics
unfortunately too many people go into
politics because they're driven by power
not enough people go into politics
before because they want to save this
country and so statesman not going in to
make friends a statesman not going in
because he needs to make money on the
side like many of these you know
speakers of houses and governors and
congressmen that all of a sudden going
broke and next you know they're worth
100 million dollars a statement is going
in because they want to save this
country and they love america we don't
have enough statesmen we have way too
many politicians and last but not least
is gaslighting you know what gas lining
is like misinformation confusing you
roses are not red roses are really green
you just can't see it
three times three is not nine why can't
it be eight maybe it's eight maybe in a
different dimension three times three is
three and you sit there like
maybe he's right maybe in a different
dimension three times three is a
confusing the living crap out of you to
question common sense right which goes
back here so these are some of the ones
that we have here as well as the obvious
ones i'm curious to know what else you
would add to the list of what i just
covered here today okay so if you
enjoyed today's video i got two other
videos i want to recommend you one of
them is an interview i did with john
perkins former economic hit man he would
go to governments and say hey if you
don't do this here's what we're going to
do to you if you've never watched this
video fascinating and the other one is
history of taxes and what if you want to
find out
taxes you know all these different
stories that we hear about taxes well
they've been around forever you will be
very surprised
on how some temporary taxes became
permanent if you've never watched that
before i would probably highly recommend
this over this one here but you pick and
choose which one you want to watch and
having said that if you want to get
today's notes in a pdf text to you text
us at zero three four zero one one three
two the word threats plural threats text
threats to three one zero three four
zero one one three two we'll send a pdf
to you and if you're international
subscribe to our newsletter we'll send
the pdf to you as well take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you